The SCP Foundation depends on staying out of
the public eye, and away from public perception,
in order to accomplish their vital work. If the
public were to find out about the Foundation and
the nightmares it spends every day protecting us
from, it would be total chaos, worldwide. They
would be so busy trying to field attention
from civilians, politicians, and reporters,
fending off every random Joe with a smartphone who
wanted to take an Instagram story of SCP-096 and
endanger his life, that they wouldn’t have time to
contain all the world-ending anomalies out there.
So, they operate entirely under the radar.
But it wasn’t always this way. There was
a time when the world at large knew about the
SCP Foundation, and the researchers had to find
out a way to step out of the spotlight for good.
Like everything else about the SCP Foundation, it
wasn’t easy. The road to the Foundation’s current
cloak of secrecy was paved with trial and error,
experimental magic, and a formidable woman
known by the alias Elizabeth Crocker. This
is the story of SCP-001 “The Frontispiece,”
also known as the Pickman-Blank proposal.
It all started in 1964, when several national
governments discovered that the Foundation’s
Overwatch Command was working both for and against
all of the countries involved in the Cold War.
Canada, the USSR, Israel and Lebanon, and
Egypt all withdrew support for the Foundation.
The most catastrophic was the withdrawal of
support from the United States government,
ordered by Lyndon B. Johnson after his national
security team discovered the Foundation had
been involved in the Cuban Missile Crisis.
At the same time as the Foundation’s relationship
with these global powers was crumbling, the
Foundation made one of its most powerful enemies
ever. Person of Interest 001, also known by
her alias “Elizabeth Crocker” was a member
of the CIA beginning in 1959. There, she fell
in love with a fellow agent named Dr. Alexandre
Hilbert, who was working on a Quantum
Brace capable of altering probability.
In 1964, the Foundation reached out to
Dr. Hilbert in an attempt to recruit him,
but he refused. Shortly after this, he was
killed during a test of the Quantum Brace.
Crocker attributed his death to the Foundation,
believing them to have tampered with his machine
in order to punish him for turning down their
offer. After the death of her love, Crocker
swore to destroy the SCP Foundation for good.
On October 19, 1967, Crocker disguised herself as
the personal driver of a member of the O5 Council
and shot her one dozen times before dropping her
body outside of a Foundation safe house in
San Francisco. A note was found on the body,
with a message from Elizabeth Crocker. It ended
with this promise: “It’s high time somebody
broke up your tidy little racket. No, more
than one somebody. Everybody. We’re going to
contain you, and you’re going to suffocate.”
Agent Crocker endangered the Foundation’s
security, seeming to possess a knowledge of
all of its outposts as well as the ability to
decipher even its most secure communications
ciphers. Several members of personnel holed
up in Havana, Cuba during January of 1968
began to brainstorm, looking for a way to
increase security and keep the Foundation
together in the face of these new threats.
A number of different researchers were
in attendance, including Dr. Arik Euler,
a Thaumatologist, or a scientist in the field of
ritual magic. Though some of his colleagues failed
to treat him with the respect he deserved, some
out of skepticism and some out of outright bigotry
toward his Jewish identity, Euler was a brilliant
mind with an idea that could save them all.
Dr. Euler proposed a potential solution to the
chaos spreading across the world, as companies
owned by the Foundation were being exposed and
destroyed and their facilities reduced to rubble.
Dr. Euler suggested that it might be possible to
place some sort of illusion over the businesses
acting as fronts for the Foundation, preventing
them from being found out by any outsiders.
Kady O’Donnel responded that that wouldn’t be
enough, that they needed to find a way to get
the world to forget the Foundation existed at all,
at least for a little while. Dr. Euler, at a loss,
reached out to Site-43 to see if they had
any thaumatologists at their facility.
There was one, in fact, Dr. Okorie. Dr. Edwin
Falkirk and Chief of Security and Containment
Martin Strauss were sent in to brief him on the
situation at hand. During their conversation,
Okorie reported thaumaturgic changes made
around his place of work. The information
he shared caught Strauss’ attention immediately.
After a moment of thought, Strauss knew exactly
what it meant and who was behind it. It was
a sign from someone who would prove immensely
helpful, and a mysterious man named Thilo Zwist.
Thilo Zwist, also known as Person of Interest-382
as well as a long list of aliases, is a highly
skilled cryptomancer, who has used his control of
anomalies to render himself functionally immortal.
He performs a form of magic using language,
and was previously associated with an organization
known as the giftschreiber, or the “Poison
Writers.” Since his discovery, Zwist has spent
decades involved in a cat and mouse game of sorts
with Site-43 Director Dr. V.L. Scout. Now, the
same Dr. Scout had planted a reference to Zwist
in the mind of Dr. Okorie, to suggest that the
Foundation contact the elusive man for help.
With this new plan in motion, Dr. Okorie attempted
to make contact with Zwist in March of 1968.
He met the man at an abandoned building
in the Harbourfront district of Toronto.
There, he found Zwist, who claimed to be
expecting him. He teased Okorie about the
unwanted attention the Foundation was receiving,
as well as the danger posed by Elizabeth Crocker.
Eventually, he asked, “Are you here to ask
for my help, or did I let you find me for
no good reason?” Okorie admitted that he was
seeking help, and Zwist explained his special
method of combining writing with ritual magic in
order to imbue the words with power or danger.
He offered to craft a phrase, a series of words
that, when written on a sign created by him, would
keep the public from seeing who the foundation
truly was. He offered to do it exactly once, but
not recreate it going forward. All he needed was
a piece of language to craft his spell. Dr. Okorie
offered an initialism as a possibility, suggesting
the “SCP” that comes before the Foundation.
Zwist laughed delightedly at this, and said
simply, “This is going to work out splendidly.”
One week later, Zwist brought Dr. Okorie a simple
logo design for a nonexistent business, called
“Scout’s Cargo Packing,” as well as a chemical
formula for an antidote that would inoculate
anyone who received it against the sign’s magical
properties. After approval by the O5 Council,
the logo was printed on a fleet of moving trucks
that could then be used to transport personnel and
items across North America without any detection.
It was highly effective, and the Foundation
began plans to spread this new protective
measure throughout all of its facilities.
In May of 1968, a collision along Route 66 in
the United States damaged one of the trucks,
removing its magical functionality. Curious about
the repercussions of Zwist’s work being destroyed,
and about any potentially dangerous
effects, Dr. Euler formed the Mimesis
and Cryptomancy Research Group, where he worked
alongside Dr. Okorie, and Dr. Ilse Reynders.
As Dr. Reynders suffered from a condition that
rendered her unable to leave a sealed chamber
in Site-43, Euler was reassigned to that facility
and worked alongside her and Okorie there. During
their research, the team learned that damage
to Zwist’s writing changed its properties in
a variety of ways, and he continued breaking
down the trucks to try and understand them.
Meanwhile, Elizabeth Crocker had not let up in her
dogged pursuit of the Foundation’s destruction.
A shipping container bearing the insignia
of a defunct Foundation front company was
discovered in the port of Los Angeles on July
2, 1968, containing the badly beaten - but still
alive - Abrasha Sokolsky. A note was pinned to
his tie, reading: “Can you feel the noose yet?”
Back at Site-43, Euler, Reynders, and Okorie
reached a breakthrough. The power of Zwist’s
work came, not from the full words of “Scout’s
Cargo Packing,” but from the initials SCP itself.
Using a combination of grammar and magic,
much to the excitement of every English
teacher and fantasy fan, they could transfer
the properties of Zwist’s sign to any other sign
bearing the same initials. Just like it always
has at the Foundation, it all came down to S. C.
P. A variety of former front
businesses were revived,
all bearing the same initials. There was Star
City Poker, Supply, Control, and Purification,
and of course, Sawyer’s Cheesy Pretzels.
The high from this breakthrough quickly
gave way to another devastating loss, however,
as Agent Crocker struck again. In Johannesburg,
South Africa, Agent Crocker infiltrated an SCP
Site under the alias “Dr. Gabrielle Fish.” There,
she exacerbated existing racial tensions and took
advantage of the Apartheid state to sow discord.
Crocker killed Regional Director Jansen
and dumped his body near Site 19,
with a note in his jacket pocket. It
said: “You’re running out of continents.”
As the research team kicked their efforts into
high gear, preparing an official research proposal
on Quantum Linguaphysics, Elizabeth Crocker
continued her grim work. In the People’s
Republic of China, she used cryptomancy to trigger
severe paranoia in Chairman Mao Zedong, drawing
his attention to Foundation representatives
hiding in the People’s Republic of China.
This forced Dr. Noble to escape the country,
leaving behind any Foundation influence in China.
There was, yet again, a note left for her. “Five
minutes to midnight.” Crocker was closing in.
Next, Crocker aligned herself with US President
Richard Nixon, tipping him off to the existence
of the Foundation and convincing him to have
the US Army occupy the facility. Euler, Okorie,
and Reynders had to act, and act fast. Each of
the Doctors tentatively signed off on the project,
ready to put the experiment into practice.
Meanwhile, Crocker got bolder
and more violent. She killed Foundation
personnel whenever she got the chance,
abandoning long-form political strategy in
favor of spectacle. She used an auditory
cryptomantic agent, embedded in a recording
of “I Wanna Hold Your Hand” by The Beatles,
to kill ten Foundation personnel
in a safe house in Scotland. Next,
she infiltrated Site-43, where she was
defeated by intervention from Zwist himself.
At Site-01, on July 9, 1969, Dr. Euler and
Dr. Okorie now put their creation into place,
called the Frontispiece. Within two weeks, its
effects had spread across the world, cloaking
every Foundation front in its anomalous effects.
By June of 1970, the Foundation could come out
of frightened, panicked hiding, and resume
regular hiding. They were working actively in
the world again, building new sites all the time.
In August of 1971, one of the Foundation’s trucks
was unable to cross beyond the Berlin wall,
as the guards stationed there only read the
Cyrillic alphabet. Dr. Euler proposed a solution,
in the form of a New York-based artist whose work
possessed similar properties to Zwist’s writing.
This artist was a man named Andy Warhol,
and the Foundation commissioned him to create
an imagery-based version of the Frontispiece
compatible with all known languages,
allowing the effects to extend to
regions that used different alphabets.
In the later 1970s, Crocker resurfaced and
escaped custody, and shortly after Dr. Okorie
was found murdered in his home. She remained
active through the 80s, aligning herself with the
Reagan administration in an ineffective attempt to
make him launch an attack on the Foundation.
Currently, it is believed that she is dead,
as she would now be over one hundred years
old. However, if Zwist is any indication,
there are tools out there that might have allowed
her to extend her life far beyond what is natural.
To this day, the work of the
original research team lives on,
even as the scientists behind it have passed
away. It is highly effective, with one exception:
repeated exposure to anomalous activity
renders someone immune to the effects of the
Frontispiece. Otherwise, however, the Foundation
remains secured, contained, and protected.
A final letter from Thilo Zwist was discovered
among Dr. Euler’s effects after his death in 2013,
reminding them of their duty to protect
the world and do the right thing.
He ended the letter with this: “your course was
set the moment I baked that lovely little flaw
into the Writing which you stole. I robbed you
of the opportunity to become the tyrants of all
our nightmares. You will have no choice but to be
better than that, because evil only flourishes in
ease. You will never know ease. You, and those who
come after you, will need to keep doing the work.
You will get to decide how well you do it, of
course. And on that matter, I have a suggestion:
Do it right. Stop Compromising Principles.”
Now go check out “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks”
and “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King” for more
insights into the fascinating world of SCP-001!